J'ai demandé au père García de
l'accompagnera est directeur spirituel et
a beaucoup d'expérience dans des situations
de crise bien peut-être certains de
tu ne sais plus
c'est un homme très préparé que nous vivons
et nous avons une bonne vie de visage
nous menons une vie sainte
toi et moi savons pourquoi les frères
ils sont ici
aller dans un centre de prière et
pénitence ce que je dois savoir
s'ils savent pourquoi
ils sont ici
l'église se lave les mains et nous
nous restons des boucs émissaires
Avez-vous déjà pensé que vous êtes un
délinquant
j'affirme que tu
si vous l'avez fait ici je le ferai
appelle la télévision et je te dirai
tout ceci ici n'est pas parrain
c'est une prison avec des criminels
merde
et en ce moment pour toi l'église
c'est moi moi
et dieu au ciel lucide pardonne
toutes les personnes